I have a family of children.
How am I supposed to practice with so many distractions?
Yeah, it's best to give them up.
This is a very regular sort of problem we come across, isn't it?
It's really understanding that meditation isn't sitting on the cushion.
Meditation is about developing a type of awareness, a type of being in the present moment, you might say.
In the Satipatthana discourse, this discourse on how to establish awareness, there's a section there on daily life, that when you're stretching your arm, you're stretching your arm.
When you're doing this, you're doing that.
So it's really meditation in action is
doing something deliberately doing something that you actually meant to do so there are various ways we can do that it's basically always remember to do with attitude it's always to do with getting the right attitude and this sets the heart in the right direction and then that's where you put your attention so whatever you're doing in daily life whether you're looking after children or cooking or working
It's important just to stop every so often and put the right intention in your heart.
And that's the good heart.
So, generally speaking, the attitude in daily life, in terms of work and family and all that, is service.
You see?
You're serving people.
Service, you see?
So there's the good heart, and that's where you put your attention.
So, just like in meditation, you're washing the pots and you're worried,
see you find yourself worrying so you have to stop and decide now am I going to wash the pots or am I going to worry see and you make a decision I'm going to wash the pots see so you re-establish your connection with the pots when you're with children and they're getting up your nose see you stop and you say children are getting up my nose see and you re-establish your sense of service to your children and
And in a busy life, if you can actually find some time to sit in the morning, that's important because that sort of sets your mode for the day.
It's sort of like, this is the way I want to be.
I want to be bright and I want to be awake all day and aware.
And then you always end your practice with this metta, so that reconnects you with the world.
And even though we do it in a more generalized way, that doesn't mean to say that
in that practice, at the end of it, you can't bring people to mind whom you're going to meet during the day.
So some of them might be difficult.
So you meet them with no ill will, you see.
No ill will.
When you meet them, of course, a lot of ill will comes up.
See?
But you know, oh, ill will's come up.
And then you re-establish, no?
A certain open-heartedness.
At least you can establish an attitude of no harm.
Huh?
And that's
And there might be a lot of ill will to it, but at least no harm.
And sometimes when things seem to get on top of us, so many things to do all at once, just try to maintain a line of calmness through it.
And just know that when you're trying to do two things at once, there's going to be some inefficiency.
You can't do it.
But sometimes you have to do that.
You're trying to cook and the baby's crying and somebody's shouting for you.
You're going berserk, you see.
You just do the best you can.
But the driving line is just this sense of awareness.
And to be aware, you've got to be generally relaxed.
Once you get tense, it's very difficult.
And a lot of energy gets dissipated with tension and fretting and all that sort of stuff.
He just keeps stopping.
Start again.
Even if you have to do that every 10 seconds.
It doesn't matter.
You just keep stopping and starting again.
So when we talk about meditation and action, we're not talking about being self-aware.
That's often a mistake we make because in the practice of the pasana, you become very much self-aware.
You become this observer up here somewhere.
observing you see, so you think well when I go around life I've got to watch myself doing things but that's a real split in our in daily life because one minute we're aware of what we're doing next minute we're aware of myself doing yeah so even though self-awareness arises you don't develop it you know it's there but you keep putting your attention on what you're doing see and when you enter into
an action no matter what it is so looking after children doing the garden doing a piece of work see when you enter into that and you lose that sense of self you also lose a sense of time yeah then you suddenly wake up and you've been at the computer for 10 hours yeah and and you wonder where it's all gone you see but you see if you've entered into that absorption with goodwill with a sense of service and a sense of awakeness that's what you're developing see if you enter into that absorption
with anxiety or with some sort of greed or with some sort of... that's what you're developing so once you understand that we develop our personalities and characters by thinking and doing then you become much more wary about entering into what you're doing with a good intention and every time you lose it, which we will, you just start again
And in the Buddha's understanding, you can become fully liberated looking after children.
Why not?
So it's not to do with sitting on a cushion.
I mean, it helps to sit on a cushion, especially at the end of the day.
sometime after work, sometime when everything's quiet, even if it's only for 10 minutes, and just let the accumulations of the day come up, little anxieties, little irritations.
So that's a time when you just, you might actually go through the day, and as you remember things, you can feel the emotional value you've put on it.
And just to stay with that for a little while, not letting the mind think about it, so you're not trying to work something out, but just staying with the emotional value around it, and just wait for it to soften, you see.
And just to know how attachment manifests.
So, you know, parents love their children, but there's also always some attachment there because there's a self.
So how do you know when you're acting lovingly and when you're acting from attachment?
It's very difficult.
But there are certain signs.
Whenever you're getting angry with somebody, with your spouse or somebody, that's because you want them to do what you want them to do.
There's a lovely little section in the discourses where there are three fully liberated monks living together.
The Anurudhas, they're called.
And the Buddha approached them and says, how is it you live so peacefully?
I mean, he would turn up at a monastery where the monks were arguing and jumping about and making all sorts of mess.
And he said, well, he said, in the morning when I get up, I say to myself,
What if I do what the others want to?
What if I put aside what I want to do and do what the others want to do?
That puts you immediately into a very different relationship to all the people you meet.
Now, you've got to be careful there because the reason why they were living so peacefully is because the other two were saying the same thing.
If you say, why don't I put aside what I want to do and do what the others want to do, then there's a danger, of course, you're going to be manipulated
So you've got to be an abused.
So you've got to be, you know, it's not stupid.
It's not as if it's stupid, you see.
But what you're trying to do is to establish a relationship, see.
So you're awake when you see you're being used or abused.
Then, of course, you stop it, you see.
You're waking up to it.
Um...
So the two sort of main things are to remember to develop the good heart through constant intention and to keep putting your attention exactly where you want it.
So there are some days where we find it very difficult with the mind so scattered.
And you keep getting caught up in things.
You get fed up with yourself.
You get fed up with everybody else.
And there are some days it goes really smooth and you think you've made it.
foolish.
So that's it really.
It's very simple you see.
This is the this is I think what foxes us.
We expect it to be clever or difficult.
We expect some trick or other to become fully liberated.
But it's just getting the right in daily life, getting the right intention and staying awake.
And that little bit about
not confusing that self-awareness, you see.
What you want to do is to give yourself to what you're doing.
So much so that you lose that sense of self, a sense of time.
And that's your meditation in action, you see.
Is there any comments on that?
Any additions?
so how do you tell you know you're saying about stay awake so you don't get abused how do you tell the difference between you know it's a very hard call to make in practice sometimes I find oh well as I say it's up to the person isn't it to decide whether they're being abused or not it's up to the person to get that sensitivity you know and to be able to
reflect back to the person how you feel about it without getting angry I mean there's no these things aren't hard rules you know it's just a case of getting the feel that somebody's messing you about you know and you might not know it while it's happening it might be a reflection afterwards and you think could he have been making tea all day for him you know
I mean, this problem in a lot of workplaces to do with bullying, things like that, can be very subtle, you see.
Bullying can be very subtle.
If you're in a position of power over somebody, just ignoring them can be quite destructive.
And some people are highly trained to be bullied.
They train themselves.
They know exactly how to abuse people in this very subtle, easy way
And you wake up, you think, hey, hold on, what's happening?
And so that's the waking up, you see, suddenly realising that your service has been abused.
Yeah.
Well, that's very true.
Partly it's a habit.
It's just getting into the habit of stopping.
And the way you can try is that you make a determination.
You make a decision to do something.
It could be just a phone call.
And then you remind yourself, when I put that phone down, I'm just going to stop for a moment.
I'm going to go inward and see if there's been any accumulation of something during that phone call.
Then the next thing to be done.
before you make a phone call you can stop so it's it's making an intention which is clear and obvious of what you're actually going to do and making it very clear to yourself that when that intention is finished you stop for a moment it doesn't have to be long you see you don't have to sit there for an hour or you can make the next phone call it's just um tish nahan you know the he's very good he
He has this bell going off at any old time during his monastery, you see.
And even when the phone goes, you have to stop.
So it's only training.
There's something you can download.
I've got it on my computer, this mindfulness bell.
Have you come across that?
Yeah.
And you can put it on for any length of time, 20 minutes, half an hour, you see.
And then you have to train yourself to stop, because sometimes you think, oh, there's a bell.
You get on with it.
Yeah.
I've got to get rid of that.
So you've got to train yourself to stop, you see, and breathe out.
Just get that feeling of stopping.
And of course what you find is that you've actually been far more efficient.
This is the point.
You've been far more efficient.
And you've reserved a lot of energy because so much energy goes on emotional stuff which you just don't need.
A lot of energy goes in the head.
What is it, 25, 30% of our...
Our glucose is used by the brain, isn't it?
Something crazy like that, you see.
So just to relax the brain for a minute, you know.
And you do that by just repeating a little mantra to yourself, you know.
Relax.
You have to talk yourself into it.
I always quote Ajahn Tate who was a very lovely teacher in Thailand take it easy sorry make it easy I always quote that's it thank you keep it simple take it easy stay with the one who knows see keep it simple
take it easy, stay with the one who knows that's it, that's the one you've got to find out once you've cracked that you've made it so yes I'm just trying to think of it instead of saying them as distractions they're not distractions, they're only distractions
to somebody who's intent on doing this even though everything else around them is calling them to do that but it's not, they're just the next thing to be done abandon the word distractions is that alright?
isn't it selfish to meditate so much?
shouldn't we be trying to improve the lives of others in tangible ways?
yes
the problem is improving others in tangible ways this is the big problem and because of the self we tend to improve the other people's lives in tangible ways by the way we want to improve them so we end up with this do-gooder syndrome a do-gooder is somebody who wants to do you the good they want to do you
it's irrelevant whether you want it or not and it makes them feel good that's the point they're going to feel goodness sometimes it's not that there's meditation and there is this other thing they're not opposites whatever life we choose to lead that lifestyle
will determine how much time we're putting to meditation, how much time we're not.
So, if your work is one of these terrible things that you have to keep going on for 10, 12 hours a day, then that's what you have to deal with.
And in between time, you try to stop and keep this awakenedness going, try to do the morning and evening meditation, you see.
You see, when it says,
to meditate so much.
I mean, what's so much about 40 minutes in the morning and 20 minutes in the evening?
I mean, that's not so much, is it?
I mean, that's your basic, what do you say, your basic template.
40 minutes to an hour in the morning.
And then, every so often during the day, try to stop.
See if you can stop for 10 minutes occasionally.
At lunchtime, instead of yackety-yackety, if you find a quiet place, just sit quietly.
You don't have to sit in posture.
you just find a quiet place to sit and just quieten the mind quieten the heart 10 minutes 15 minutes and then in the evening when you come back now you wouldn't do that if you didn't see the effect of it on your life that's the point I mean for me it was immediate as soon as I started meditating my my life became so much easier see I was a teacher in a FE school so
you have to go from one class to another sometimes right across the college so normally speaking you'd be you'd be shouting at somebody and then you'd bang the door and then you'd be rushing to the next class you know with all your stuff under your arm but then you see I began to realize through the meditation that the movement from one place to another was a time just to collect yourself so the whole day became so much calmer you know so much calmer just simple things like that and uh
You wouldn't do that if you didn't realize what sort of mind or awareness you're trying to develop.
And that's what the Vipassana is doing.
It's trying to help us realize that there's a way of being aware, which is awake and alive, and it's engaged in the sitting.
It's engaged in the sense of really feeling and seeing things.
And in the world of doing things, being in your doing, being your doing.
Ram Dass, very good book.
being you're doing it's an old one but it's still worth reading and then you realise that and then what you discover I think most people begin to experience is that when they drop when the meditation drops off their life starts going back to the old habits and then you realise ah hold on that was the purpose of my meditation and then you need little Philips during the year you know you need to do a day retreat occasionally if you can get away for a week
And these lift your practice.
Lift your practice.
So there's nothing wrong with trying to help people.
It's just that you're not out there for yourself.
This is very difficult.
You're not out there trying to make yourself happy through helping others.
You may be happy helping others, but that's not the reason you're doing it.
Now you may say to yourself consciously, oh I'm doing it for their benefit.
And then when somebody, you know, when you, I mean my usual example, for those who know me, you know, you make this soup for somebody and they say, because they're ill, and they say, well I don't, I don't want the soup.
Stick with this soup now.
Took me two hours.
And they say, do me a favour.
I say, what's that?
It's a cleaner toilet.
Let's have a cup of cleaner toilet.
I've made this soup.
Ha!
Of course you do, you clean the toilet but you're grumbling.
And then that awful business of saying yes too quick.
Will you help me move house?
Oh yeah, where's he going?
And you have to start lying.
I feel really ill, I can't go.
All sorts of dead ends.
So I would abandon trying to help others.
I'd wait for somebody to ask me to help them.
That's a safer patch.
Yeah, would anybody like to add to that?
You said that when we feel strong negative emotions we should allow ourselves to feel them fully and they will burn themselves out.
What can we do
when the pain of these emotions feel so overwhelming and when we simply feel we do not have the strength to endure until the emotion passes yeah now when it's when it feels overwhelming like that you you have to park them see I try to make a distinction between suppressing something and parking it so when you suppress something you're doing it out of anger you're doing it out of aversion you're out of fear see now when you do that you're just adding more more bad
energy into the system but if you say well you know this is too much it's too much you see you say do you stay there for a minute you say you talk to you stay there for a minute and I'll have a cup of tea see I'll call up a friend I'll do something or I'll go for a walk see so you don't have to you don't have to you don't have to be overwhelmed in that sense and of course sometimes it feels like that because when you open up to yourself you know you're taking away these suppressive measures so
You're sitting there, for instance, and the fear comes up and you don't want to feel this, you see, and a bit afraid of it, some anxiety, a sense of panic, you see.
So you stay with the panic.
But when that panic and when that sense of fear of what you're going to experience and the aversion to it disappears, this stuff's then allowed to manifest.
So don't be surprised if it comes up with a whoosh.
See?
So then you, whoa, whoa, stop.
So you take a walk.
See?
And you just wait.
And then very slowly your courage comes, you see.
You get more courage and you're able to sit with it.
And then you're able to sink into it, you see.
And one question that you might ask yourself is, well, what is an emotion before I give it a name?
Once you give something a name, you're into a reaction.
If you don't know what it is and you've lost some fear of it, then you can sink into it more easily.
As you know, if you have a pain, a lot of people, you know, they might feel very sick and they don't know what it is, but it turns out to be a serious disease like cancer.
There's a sort of certain relief that they know what it is.
It's better to be in a place of knowing what it is than not knowing what it is, even though it's a horrible diagnosis.
So it's the same with these emotions, you see.
We don't know the extent of them, the depth of them.
And you have to go sometimes a little gingerly, that's all.
Gingerly.
Does that make sense?
Anybody got any other tricks?
Just persevering.
I actually went on a retreat to help me deal with the negative emotion I was having with somebody I had to work with every single day.
And it took me three years of visiting, visiting, visiting that emotion.
I still have a little bit of a low threshold when I encounter that person.
But at least I don't feel this overwhelming, or actually ill will,
that's right and of course we know from Freud that if you do push it away it comes out in sneaky ways you know it comes out in little slips of the tongue just the way you look at them which makes everything worse yeah
Well, congratulations for not slipping into murder.
Coastal.
You mentioned earlier when talking about identification that there can be moments of this.
and all our suffering begins but identification can often be seen in interpersonal relationships as a kind of empathy with another's pain is there wholesome and unwholesome identification or do we just get it all confused?
No, when I talk about identification I'm talking about identifying with what is unwholesome what is unwholesome?
When, if you watch how the mind works, say, you know, you see somebody whom you don't like, you see, first of all, as soon as you see them, which is the immediate contact, there's a reaction, you don't like, you don't like.
And then there's an identification with that reaction, I don't like.
And this immediately turns into a train of thoughts or an action of speech or body.
And that's creating your conditioning, that's your becoming.
That's what the Buddha means by becoming, karma.
Now, so long as we are aware of that dislike, we're not developing it.
It remains there as
a difficult feeling it remains there as unpleasant but the one that knows isn't actually suffering until they become I am angry or I am depressed to make that distinction really you have to in your meditation when say a negative state comes up
Some sort of anxiety.
And you're feeling it.
It's become quite objective to you.
You feel it, you see.
So, you know, just reflect on that.
Yes, there's an interior unpleasant feeling, unpleasant environment, interior unpleasant environment.
But that which knows isn't actually suffering.
It's observing it.
if you can make that clear to yourself then you see that the problem starts when we slip into this I am, I am depressed etc.
see now when it's on the positive side I want to do something for somebody I love somebody I'm rejoicing in that person's success there's still that identification
of I am the one who is rejoicing I am the one who loves and all that so there's still delusion there but it's developing the good heart you see so in the Buddhist therapy we are letting go of unwholesome states which are causing us problems and we're moving towards wholesome states so that we're developing the beautiful mind see
But the delusion is still there that I am happy, I am the one who's happy, the I business, okay?
Now it's when that is strong, when the more beautiful the heart is, the easier it is to see that delusion and to drop it.
It's very difficult to drop the delusion of I when you're in a lot of pain, when you're in a lot of emotional pain, okay?
Now, if you think of other therapies, other ways of seeing that, in the Christian way, you've got sinfulness.
So that's their way of saying this unfortunate conditioning, sinfulness.
And on the other side, you've got God and the commandments and the guidance, and you've got this free will.
So this free will now has to decide whether it wants to go towards hell or towards heaven.
And by realizing what the choice is, one hopes to make those choices that are moving us towards heaven.
Now if you look at the Freudian model, instead of sin, you've got id.
Id, terrible id, which is animal and dreadful.
And on the other side, you've got superego.
the voices of your parents and the Bible and the Buddha and in the middle you've got this poor ego trying to navigate some sort of decent life for itself so it's always the same thing it's just looking at it from different angles from the Buddha's point of view the problem is ethical and that would be the same as the Christian point of view the problem is ethical
which really in its broadest sense of that meaning is our relationships how do you relate to other people how do you relate to other animals and birds and all that how do you relate to objects see how do you close your fridge door well you should be ashamed you should be very gently so it's by correcting our
The negative side of us, the unwholesome side, you see, by simply not indulging those intentions.
And by indulging those intentions that are beneficial to us.
Now there's still a bit of a self there, but we're getting much more beautiful in ourselves.
I'm using the word beautiful because that's the way the Buddha talks about the mind.
Beautiful mind, you see.
so that's what the identification is see so long as there's an identification with this psycho-physical organism as being me even in the most subtle ways I'll be seeking happiness through it and it's not going to deliver so I've got to search for happiness in a different place
Where are we going to find the happiness the Buddha talks about?
So again, like I said this morning, as you relocate back into the knower, into the observer, the feeler, and that becomes a very strong experience for you, separate from the body with its sensations, the heart with its emotions, the mind with its thoughts and images.
Even there, afterwards you can reflect, what was it like being there?
now you may at first be very disappointed because it's completely unexciting but actually there's no suffering there and the more you stay in that place even during daily life even during your actions which is to be aware just to be aware the cooler our lives become see the cooler and there's a deep happiness
because life isn't about chasing the next excitement it's about meaningfulness we'll suffer anything as long as it's meaningful take a look at these political activists torture all that sort of stuff but for them it makes their life utterly meaningful and therefore the experience
a profound happiness about himself.
How's that then?
Any comments?
Observations?
Criticism?
Yeah?
How much of your day do you listen to the news or do you...
Well, unfortunately, I've become a bit of an aficionado.
That's because of this damn computer.
And you just click and you get BBC and Al Jazeera.
Yeah, depressing.
You don't limit yourself particularly.
Well, I try, you know, when I'm listening to the news, when I remember, I try to send out a bit of a thought of loving kindness to these people.
But it's also, remember, that we suffer from a sense of impotence when we see these things.
And really that's a case of being humble, which is recognizing exactly where we are in the scheme of things when it comes to power.
The amount we can do is extraordinarily limited.
And the amount that we can influence other people to do what we want them to do is very limited.
And it's a case of saying, well, that's it, that's all I can do.
and being happy with that being content with it knowing that you're not asked to do anymore that's the limit of you know and just to accept that we are in fact moving slowly but surely towards complete destruction yippee let it come that's what I say
Being clever animals, we will, you know, a few will survive and write a new book called, you know, Survival, which will replace all these other books like the Bible and the Buddha's teachings.
Yeah, very unfortunate.
What to do?
So, yes, we've come to the end a little bit late.
Can I leave you with a little blessing?
The blessing is may you enjoy good fortune.
May all the gods and beings that can protect us protect you.
May the force be with you.
And may you receive the blessings of the Bodhidhamma Sangha.
Bhava to Saba, Mangalang, Rakhan to Saba.
Do you know this one?
Oh, you do?
Ah, chance to go.
No, I just keep it.